el expresidente brasileño prestó
declaración durante cerca de dos horas
en la sede de la Policía Federal los
delegados le interrogaron sobre un único
asunto el motivo por el cual fue
convocado un vídeo que compartió en sus
redes sociales dos días después del
ataque a la plaza de los tres poderes
cuyo contenido volvía a cuestionar la
transparencia de las elecciones ganadas
por Lula Los investigadores veían esta
publicación como un indicio que
incentivó el asalto a la plaza de los
tres poderes a la salida del
interrogatorio uno de sus Abogados del
carro la prensa que el expresidente hizo
esa publicación por error en su página
Facebook cuando en realidad intentaba
enviarlo a su WhatsApp para poder verla
después
una torpeza que fue causada según su
defensa por la morfina que él estaba
tomando en un hospital de Orlando cuando
hizo la publicación una explicación que
convence a pocos ya que el perfil
oficial
publicó durante semanas y meses muchos
contenidos falsos sobre las elecciones
antes del ataque del 8 de enero desde su
vuelta de Estados Unidos hace menos de
un mes es la segunda vez que bolsonaro
presta declaración ante la policía
federal la primera fue en otra
investigación sobre el ingreso irregular
al país de joyas muy valiosas regaladas
por Arabia Saudita y en total el
expresidente de extrema derecha enfrenta
decenas de procesos y cuatro
investigaciones en el supremo tribunal
Federal